medical experts say there is a chance  that we'll better manage covet 19 this  year doctors think the virus won't  really ever go away but it will become  easier to deal with and that could  happen sooner than we think  when we look historically at pandemics  in the human population they last about  two years the viral pandemics we're  about that point now we're going to  develop a herd immunity from both  vaccination and from natural infection i  think there's reason to expect a light  at the end of the tunnel  well we certainly all hope so dr khan  says the omicron variant which is the  dominant strain here in southern nevada  is mild for most vaccinated people it  says viruses like covet become less  lethal over time comparing it to the flu  or common cold there is however no set  timeline for when covet will become  easier to manage it really all just  depends on future variants